[Music]
[Music]
Sallis get yourselves up
Wyatt okay
[Music]
Hancock's latest act of so-called
heroics has once again enraged city
officials I can smell that liquor on
your breath
Mondragon
shotguns call me a jackass one more time
check about you thickness goggles ha I
knew you'd come not okay I do public
relations people don't like you Hancock
but I look like I care what people think
right now is a DEA trying to figure how
to come up here and put you in jail I
say you go mm-hmm he's not gonna go
people take you for granted you know we
got to make people miss you you don't
move your head on a business jail watch
day five in crime is still on the rise
phone call it's the chief of police he
says he needs your help
you gotta calm your hero Hancock you're
gonna be miserable the rest of your life
if you accept that life here can be
difficult for me after all I'm the only
one of my kind you deserve better from
me I will be better
I'm wearing that what it's a little
tight I need you in this to touch your
body
different
[Music]
hey caca del looks hurt
that's it take a look hard
[Music]